Any
software you install onto your computer
or server at your company usually
includes some type of license. The terms
of this license are usually presented
during the installation process. It's
that long contract that you always
scroll all the way through and click
okay at the bottom. Inside of that
license includes terms and conditions
that set the overall use of the
software, how many copies of this
software you can make, and what your
backup options for the software might
be. Many of these terms and conditions
also include information about how the
software is licensed. It might be a per
seat license. So, when you purchase one
license, that one license is assigned to
a seat. That's usually a person that's
in your organization. If you have 20
people that need to use this software,
then you'll need 20 per seat licenses.
Some software is licensed as a
concurrent license, which determines how
many people can use this software
concurrently. So, if there's 20 people
in your organization that need to use
this license, but only 10 of those
people will be using it at any
particular time, then you only need 10
concurrent licenses. Some software is
licensed by duration. This is a ongoing
subscription that you might use based on
an annual subscription, a three-year
subscription, or some other time frame.
In most of these cases, you are able to
use the software up until that
expiration date, and then past that
point, you will need to relic the
software to continue to use it.
If you're purchasing a license of
software to use at home, this is usually
a personal license. This is usually
associated with the computer that you're
using, although there is some software
that allows you to install it on
multiple devices within your own home.
And in the home market, this software is
often licensed on a perpetual basis.
That means you pay one cost to be able
to use this software, and you don't have
to pay any additional costs in the
future. In a corporate environment, we
have many more people that need to use
this software. So we might purchase per
seat licenses or it might be a site
license where we can install this
software on all of our systems in the
company. These types of licenses usually
come with an annual renewal. So you have
to make sure that you pay your renewal
cost every year to keep using that
software.
The software might be available online
and you might have direct access to the
source code. Very often this is software
that is licensed as free and open-source
software or foss. This free and open
source software comes with the source
code. You can modify the source code and
compile the source code yourself to run
on your own computers. This is very
different, for example, than purchasing
software from a company like Microsoft.
Microsoft does not provide you with the
source code. They simply give you an
executable that will run on the
platforms that you're using. With closed
source software, you don't have any
access to the code and you have no way
to modify any part of that application.
That long list of terms and conditions
that you see during the installation
process is known as an enduser licensing
agreement or a ULA. This is effectively
an online contract that you must agree
to before you're able to continue with
that installation process.
There may be times when one of your
software vendors would like to stop by
and demonstrate pre-release capabilities
of software that may be coming in the
future. But before they show you this
pre-release software, they require you
to sign a non-disclosure agreement or an
NDA. This is a confidentiality
agreement. It ensures that one or more
people involved in the contract will not
disclose what they've seen to anyone
else. This is very common when you're
working with a third party and you need
some type of privacy or confidentiality
between these parties. This might be to
maintain trade secrets, or perhaps we
just don't want any of these business
activities to be known by anyone else.
The example of a software company having
a meeting with you to show you
pre-release software may require a
unilateral NDA. But if you're also
sharing information with the software
company, you might need a bilateral NDA
where both parties maintain the
confidentiality of what's talked about
during that meeting. These are formal
contracts. They'll usually slide a piece
of paper across the table that you'll
need to sign to confirm that you agree
with everything listed in that
non-disclosure agreement.
The credit card industry has created
comprehensive rules regarding the
processing and storage of credit card
information. We refer to this as the
payment card industry data security
standard or PCIDSS.
You'll often hear people abbreviate this
as simply PCI. A summary of just part of
the PCIDSS
revolves around six control objectives.
So you need to make sure that you build
and maintain a secure network and secure
systems that are on that network. You
have to protect card holder data
especially if you are storing that
information. You need to maintain a
vulnerability management program. This
ensures that the credit card company
knows that you are performing constant
audits to keep your network safe. You
need to provide strong access control
measures. So there might not only be a
username and password but also
multiffactor authentication. There needs
to be a regular monitoring and testing
of all of your networks and you should
maintain an information security policy
which is really a good best practice
whether you're protecting credit card
information or any other type of data.
We also store a great deal of private
information with our governments.
Government information is used for
social security purposes. There's
personal information on your driver's
license, and many governments have a
great deal of health care information
that they also store. There are most
likely a number of restrictions
associated with the collection and
storage of government information. So,
you'll need to check with your local
laws to see what you're able to do with
government data and what information
you're not allowed to collect.
Unfortunately, this collection of
information by the government can
sometimes be a disadvantage. For
example, in July of 2015, the OPM or the
Office of Personnel Management was
compromised and personal information was
leaked onto the internet. This included
names, social security numbers, date of
birth, job assignments, and other
private information. A total of 21 12
million people were affected by this
government breach.
Any data that you can use to identify an
individual is referred to as PII. This
is personally identifiable information.
It's usually a good idea when you're
writing security policies to document
how your organization will handle PII.
We often forget how valuable this
personal information can be. We
sometimes think of a name and an address
as something that is easily available to
anyone, but in reality that combined
with other pieces of information can
create a privacy issue. So we have to
think about how we use this PII as a
normal part of our data processing and
how we protect that information from
others. We often use PII as a security
tool and attackers love to get their
hands on personal information because it
might gain them access to bank account
information or they may be able to
perform a password reset because the
password reset process is asking about
personal details that are part of this
PII.
A similar type of personal information
that focuses on health care information
is PHI, protected health information.
This might include your health care
records, your health status, or anything
else associated with your medical
history. Of course, we use many
different healthcare providers in our
day-to-day life. And there are standard
ways that these providers can transfer
your PHI from one of the providers to
another over a secure channel. In the
United States, we have laws associated
with protected health information known
as HIPPA. This is the Health Insurance
Portability and Accountability Act of
1996.
Your organization may have a process in
place to store information over a long
period of time. And it may also include
versioned information over that long
period of time. So there might be a
document that has changed today, that
document may be different tomorrow, and
it might be updated again the day after.
Part of your job might be to retain all
of these different versions and have a
way that we can revert back to a
previous version at any time. We might
also have data retention requirements
based around the recovery of data. For
example, if our organization is infected
with a virus or a worm, we might need a
way to go back in time up to 30 days to
be able to recover some of our company's
data. And often data retention is built
into the laws that we must follow as
part of our normal business practices.
For example, if you're in a legal firm
or you work for the government, there
might be laws that require email to be
retained over a number of years. Or if
you're a public corporation, there might
be requirements to store tax information
or financial details for a long period
of time. You'll need to check with the
laws in your area or that deal with your
organization to see what the data
retention requirements might be for you.
When you start working for a company,
they might ask you to sign a document
known as an AUP. This is an acceptable
use policy. This is a set of
documentation that describes how the
technology you've been given should be
used as part of your normal job
function. For example, your company
might have specific rules associated
with using the internet, telephones,
computers, mobile devices, and any other
type of technology. This documentation
is often used by an organization to
limit their legal liability. If somebody
needs to be dismissed from the
organization due to a misuse of the
technology, they have documentation
signed by you that says that you will
agree with these rules and regulations.
Another way to inform people of an
expectation on a system is to provide
that message when they're logging in. We
often refer to this message as a splash
screen. Sometimes this splash screen is
simplyformational and telling you what
is expected of you when you're using
this particular service. or this might
be a legal requirement and you're
required to agree with this splash
screen before you're able to use this
service. For example, if I want to use
the geographical information service
from my local government, there's a
splash screen that is presented during
the login process. This splash screen
says if you have any web accessibility
issues with this site, here's an email
contact or phone number during normal
Orange County government business hours.
And they give that as Monday through
Friday 8 to 5:00. And then they show
that the data is provided as is without
any warranty, any representation of
accuracy and more legal information
that's important to know as you're using
this data from this government agency.